guys great job tonight these things are
done by teams and I've got the best team
in television I'm gonna make sure each
and every one of you knows how important
you are to me this isn't our control
room No
screw it first Emmy Award for portraying
a news anchor we like that in Aaron
Sorkin's hit series the newsroom now
he's nominated for 2019 Tony Award his
third one by the way thank you very much
he stars a small-town lawyer Atticus
Finch Sorkin's adaptation of Harper
Lee's classic To Kill a Mockingbird
now the story shines a light on racial
prejudice in the deep south by focusing
on Finch's defense of Tom Robinson a
black man wrongly accused of assaulting
a white woman back in the 1930s we have
to show Tom Robinson justice in this
courtroom now we can start gathering the
animals two by two because we'll be
showing God's justice in a hurry we
can't go on like this we know that
so let's hasten the change that's a sin
the end of the beginning let's do it
right now in Maycomb let's begin by
restoring this man to his family let's
begin with justice that's just one of
the reasons he was nominated for a Tony
Award good morning to you Jeff Daniels
back here you know and in the book and
in the movie with Gregory Peck Atticus
Finch was flawless in this particular
adaptation he's not so flawless he's a
human being
yeah aaron sorkin when he wrote the play
based on the book wanted to take the
statue down the the point of view in the
book is pretty much scout looking up at
the Great Father and we wanted to kind
of get eye on eye level with him and we
always took the approach that he was a
small-town lawyer who got paid and
vegetables sometimes he handled land
dispute service agreements foreclosures
that was it and one day the judge comes
over and changes his life that's where
we started so that everything happens to
him
versus starting up here you called the
role of a lifetime hope for you to play
no because it you you've been I've been
waiting for something like this forever
I've had great roles you know throughout
the career but the stars align you got
Sorkin writing at bars you're directing
it's the Shubert theater which is like
the Carnegie Hall of Broadway you're
Atticus Finch the fictional hero of I
mean people think this guy's lived that
he was I mean and they certainly the
first month of the run people came to
the show with the book against their
chest going please don't ruin this
please don't I mean that's beloved so to
get the chance to play that kind of hero
that kind of iconic guy and then to pull
him off and make him human be a human
being where he has to change he has to
go through he has to deal with his own
beliefs and it's it's a really it kind
of peels the layers back of Atticus and
Atticus has these and beliefs that would
stand everything around him and that's
what makes him the hero and then that
changes and watching him and it feels so
contemporary even that was written in
the night oh yeah
Sorkin did a beautifully I mean it's 34
Alabama but it's today I mean Atticus
believes that there's goodness and
everyone you just have to care enough to
look for it well that's up for grabs
right now points out that that view ends
up hurting other people more yes it does
Calpurnia has got a voice Tom Robinson
has a voice this is different to black
characters back then did not have a
voice no and it's hard to say what
Calpurnia and if Calpurnia and Atticus
were brother and sister which is what
their kind of relationship is over the
years maybe they were able to do that
they didn't do it in the book they
didn't do it in the movie but could that
have existed sure but in the place she
definitely has something to say and she
calls Atticus out she's she's the one
who goes wait a minute hang on you're
wrong 9 Tony nominations I think to kill
Mockingbird has just been named the
highest-grossing Broadway play of all
time yeah
what is it do you think about this cast
that makes it such an incredible
production we it's hard to do a play
eight times a week month after month
after month
we're in our seventh month and there is
a way to do it where you're I call it
the mule on the trail you're just going
you to going down to the bottom of a
Grand Canyon again and you really don't
have to and you're saying the speech but
you're really thinking about where
you're gonna eat and I've seen that
where people actually look like that but
you know we keep it alive we stay in the
same Lane head in the same place we
don't deviate stage you ever change
staging anything but it's alive if you
throw it at me different today I'm
coming at you oh I'll be over here now
great let's do it and it's alive and the
audience feels of vibrancy and an
urgency and it's a little less it's a
lot less we're gonna go to you on
Broadway we're gonna go to you the
audience we're here but we're gonna go
to you and studies we're here you come
here you come here you come on stage
with us we pull you in so that you watch
the movie you read the book you feel the
play and I think that's the big takeaway
from Mockingbird on Broadway people walk
out changed but they definitely are
feeling something thinking wow they're
thinking I went to it alone and walked
out like I'd been hit by a by a train
everybody else is so powerful and to to
weep in the seats is an amazing thing to
create that kind of art that where the
audience can react like that you've done
something amazingly we hear the weeping
- we hear them weeping when the
nomination was announced and called your
name you did you were awake to hear it
right it did mean something URI I tried
to but I had to sit there and go am I
going to hear my name or not is this
going to be a good six months or am I
now and it did I was very happy to Jeff
Daniels To Kill a Mockingbird on
Broadway right now we'll be right back
you